[Música]
según el banco mundial una persona
promedio le va a dedicar 113 mil horas
de su vida a trabajar
eso sí lo ponemos en cantidades de años
es el equivalente a 12
pero 12 años seguidos 24 horas al día 7
días a la semana
y en ese mismo estudio también se
descubre de que una persona promedio le
va a dedicar aproximadamente 7 mil 800
horas a estar con amigos
nuevamente si hacemos la matemática eso
es un poco menos de un año
cuando caí en cuenta de la cantidad de
horas que yo le iba a dedicar de la
cantidad de horas de vida en mi vida que
yo le iba a dedicar a trabajar
rápidamente me surgió esta pregunta que
voy a hacer con esos 12 años
porque mi intención era que solamente
pasen sino que realmente se queden cuál
cuál es el significado de esos 12 años
en mi vida cuál es el impacto que yo voy
a generar en ese tiempo
y la verdad si bien tenía este
cuestionamiento no tenía una respuesta
en un principio porque como la mayoría
de jóvenes tenía esta inquietud y esta
intención de querer ir a una universidad
conseguir un buen trabajo
tener un buen sueldo lograr en algún
momento tener un título que sonase
interesante
y escalar en una gran corporación o
emprender pero por otro lado
genuinamente también tenía una gran
inquietud de saber y ver qué cosas yo
podía hacer para tratar de de alguna
manera encontrar soluciones para todos
estos desafíos que tenemos como
humanidad
y
no tenía una respuesta a esta pregunta
tampoco y de pronto
pasaron los años y me di cuenta de que
involuntariamente terminé eligiendo como
mis indicadores de éxito igualmente a mi
escala a mi progreso en el trabajo
al incremento salarial a mi bono de fin
de año
y así seguir conviviendo con esta
atención pasé por distintas experiencias
trabajé en distintas organizaciones de
hecho pasé por varias organizaciones de
distintas industrias y yo también estuve
en distintas posiciones y curiosamente
ahora que lo miré en retrospectiva
caigo en cuenta de qué manera super
orgánica había
todo el tiempo estaba buscando cuál es
el impacto que yo estaba generando en
ese espacio o incluso pensando qué
impacto estaba generando esa
organización o inclusive a veces pensaba
qué impacto podríamos generar
de hecho hay un momento
muy importante y fundamental para mí
dentro de esas experiencias durante casi
dos años trabajé como relacionista
comunitario en una empresa minera a más
de 4000 metros sobre el nivel del mar y
mi rol ahí
un poco en resumen consistía en lograr
que ambas la empresa y la comunidad
llegasen a un punto medio
si es que la empresa quería algo de la
comunidad indefectiblemente tenía que
también la empresa darle algo a la
comunidad así como funciona el mercado
damos x a cambio y
y si bien podríamos digamos de manera
más básica definir al mercado como ese
espacio en donde encontramos a
compradores y a vendedores también
identifique en esta experiencia de que
más allá de esta lógica de intercambio
que se mantiene si han habido mecanismos
que han ido modificándose en el tiempo
en esta misma lógica como por ejemplo en
las comunidades altoandinas con el
trueque al mismo tiempo están dando algo
a cambio de algo
y
de pronto me di cuenta de que
el mercado es una condición inherente a
la humanidad es algo con lo que vamos a
vivir
el mercado es inherente al humanidad nos
acompaña desde muchos muchos años y en
este paso de trabajar como humanidad con
el mercado también hemos creado nosotros
mismos desafíos que hoy son super
negativos para la humanidad de hecho hoy
estamos enfrentando problemas reales y
urgentes y que debemos de alguna manera
abordarlos
y me gustaría darles algunos ejemplos
según por ejemplo oxfam hay 26 personas
aquí hay 400 o sea 26 personas es un
grupito por acá que representan el
equivalente a la mitad de la riqueza de
la población mundial 26 personas que
representan a 3.500 millones de personas
por otro lado según las naciones unidas
en el 2018 una migración de
aproximadamente 69 millones de personas
eso es el equivalente al reino unido-
más o menos que emigraron de sus casas
por pobreza o por la crisis climática o
por las guerras o por hambre
y si podemos abordar la lógica de cómo
estamos gestionando también nuestros
desechos y cómo estamos gestionando
nuestros alimentos también lo estamos
haciendo pésimo de hecho hay un 30% de
los desechos de alimentos que en
realidad no son desechos que podrían
utilizarse aún y en contraparte tenemos
a más de 800 millones de personas que
están consideradas como que sufren
hambre crónico si gestionamos bien esos
3 ese 30% probablemente no habría hambre
crónico en el mundo
así que esta tensión entre mis
aspiraciones profesionales
y mis aspiraciones y digamos el impacto
que yo estaba generando cada vez hizo
más fuerte y aquí llegó con con un
momento en mi vida que me parece curioso
y hecho en esta charla también mientras
la preparada que es todo esto que les he
contado era una inquietud de sólo una
persona sólo mía y me pregunto qué pasa
con el resto de personas que trabajan en
las más de 125 millones de empresas que
hay en el mundo y no sólo eso sino que
pasa con esas 113 mil horas que cada una
de estas personas le va a dedicar a
trabajar en dónde está el impacto
de pronto yo seguía con esta atención
pero lo bueno es que la compartía era
una atención compartida con personas muy
cercanas a mí mis hermanos mis mejores
amigos y nos rompíamos la cabeza
pensando qué cosas podríamos hacer al
respecto
y teníamos este cuestionamiento de
podremos de alguna manera generar un
emprendimiento o hacer una empresa que
genere rentabilidad pero que al mismo
tiempo de alguna manera podamos estar
abordando los desafíos sociales y
ambientales y si bien nosotros estamos
convencidos de que no estábamos
inventando la pólvora con esta pregunta
tratando de responder a esta pregunta no
sabíamos bien muy bien dónde buscar y en
ese momento dijimos bueno igual pensemos
en una idea se nos ocurrió una idea pero
también investigamos para ver si es que
esto puede ser viable o no en el medio
de esta investigación y mientras
estábamos construyendo este
emprendimiento nos encontramos con un
documental llamado not business as usual
y ese documental fue un momento muy
especial para nosotros porque por un
lado descubrimos que no estábamos
inventando la pólvora por otro lado
descubrimos que no estábamos solos
y también descubrimos de que habían
empresas en el mundo que estaban siendo
competitivas en lo económico pero que
también estaban abordando los desafíos
sociales y ambientales y que por otro
lado había una organización llamada beat
lab como el laboratorio be que operaba
en estados unidos y en canadá que se
encargaba de darle
veamos de hacer viables de demostrar de
que estas empresas eran viables y darles
credibilidad también
fue un momento increíble para nosotros
porque descubrimos que habían empresas y
organizaciones que estaban haciendo lo
mismo y que de pronto se resumía un poco
en que las empresas habían descubierto
de que tenían que moverse en esta misma
lógica de mercado y de intercambio pero
entendían de que en esta lógica del
mercado no solamente habían compradores
y vendedores habían muchos más personas
y está sucediendo habían muchas más
cosas interactuando en este entra en
este intercambio estaban obviamente los
vendedores estaban los compradores pero
también estaba la comunidad también
estaban los colaboradores de la empresa
también estaba el medio ambiente
la verdad que nos dimos cuenta de que de
pronto eran empresas que no habían
cambiado las reglas del juego que
simplemente lo que habían hecho era
mejorar las condiciones era mejorar un
poco lo que ya se estaba haciendo
investigando un poco más descubrimos
también de que esta organización no solo
estaba operando en eeuu y en canadá que
no era algo tan lejano de hecho había
una organización melliza
que existía ya hace algunos años llamada
sistema de aquí en latinoamérica en
nuestra región y que estaban haciendo lo
mismo que vila pero tratando de entender
cuál era el contexto de la región porque
al fin y al cabo los contextos de las
regiones si varían y de manera más
coincidente aún descubrimos de que el
capítulo en perú recién estaba
comenzando
no voy a creerlo y si bien
yo
que estaba viviendo esta tensión en mi
vida profesional
de pronto descubro este documental que
me ayuda a reconocer de que se podían
hacer cosas como las que queríamos hacer
con mis hermanos y que al mismo tiempo
descubro que había una organiza con una
organización que nos ayuda a validar y
darle credibilidad a lo que nosotros ya
queríamos hacer y que esa organización
estaba comenzando sus operaciones en
lima en perú me hizo tanto sentido que
de manera hasta como contraintuitiva y
hablando con mis hermanos tomé la
decisión de aventurarme a liderar
sistema de perú a postular para liderar
al sistema de perú a pesar de que yo
estaba construyendo un proyecto de vida
con mis hermanos
y que creo que el sistema de sistema de
en definitiva es un movimiento es un
movimiento global que busca redefinir el
sentido del éxito en la economía
nosotros durante muchos años hemos
utilizado la habilidad empresarial para
maximizar la rentabilidad de las
empresas y desde sistema estamos
convencidos de que esa habilidad
empresarial puede y debe utilizarse para
maximizar la rentabilidad de las
empresas pero también para afrontar y
buscar soluciones a los desafíos
sociales y ambientales
las empresas que buscamos son se llaman
empresas y estas empresas tienen cuatro
elementos
por un lado las empresas deben tener un
sentido de propósito y una motivación
que está alineada y balanceada entre lo
económico lo social y lo ambiental por
otro lado este propósito que puede ser
sólo una declaración en sistema de
pedimos de que se ancla en los
documentos más relevantes de una empresa
que son sus estatutos y de esta manera
el propósito ya deja de ser una
declaración y se convierte en un
compromiso legal
en tercer lugar invitamos a que las
empresas tienen una evaluación de más o
menos 180 indicadores
es un poco tedioso en donde te da y
ofrece una mirada integral de cuál es el
impacto que una empresa puede estar
generando
en cuarto lugar
al igual que las personas invitamos a
que las empresas también se reconozcan
como seres interdependientes que
necesitamos estar juntos y sumar
esfuerzos para hacerle frente a los
desafíos de la humanidad
las empresas que quieren ganar plata
pero no a cualquier costo y como no lo
quieren hacer a cualquier costo
desde sistema de estamos buscando esos
mecanismos y esas condiciones para que
puedan haber más empresas de este tipo
por ejemplo trabajamos con políticas
públicas para que pronto hayan
mecanismos que validen a este tipo de
empresas desde lo público
por otro lado también trabajamos con
inversionistas y conversamos con ellos y
los invitamos a que tengan interés en
invertir en organizaciones como estas
de pronto terminemos conversaciones con
líderes de opinión porque consideramos
de que esto tiene que llegar a todo el
mundo tiene que llegar a la sociedad
civil y tiene que llegar también a los
consumidores y en cuarto lugar también
trabajamos con la academia porque
estamos convencidos de que al igual que
como yo descubrí ese documental existen
casos de éxito que están sucediendo hoy
en muchos lugares del mundo y que
tenemos que ponerlos al servicio de la
gente en perú hay muchos casos en
definitiva
lo que buscan las empresas ve
es demostrar de que a mayores ventas
mayor impacto
y lo que buscamos en sistema es crear
esas condiciones necesarias para que
cada vez haya más empresas de este tipo
de trabajar algunos años en sistema de
en calle en cuenta de que lo que quiero
en lo que quiero aportar yo genuinamente
y luego de haber entendido de que esta
tensión está presente todo el tiempo y
que no está mal
lo que yo quiero aportar es desde el
lugar en donde yo estoy tratar de
generar algún impacto y alguna y buscar
alguna solución para los desafíos que
tenemos como humanidad
y
acá me gustaría
contarles una pequeña reflexión yo
siento que nosotros solemos admirar a
muchas personas y las consideramos
extraordinarias
por definición extraordinario quiere
decir algo que es poco común
también tiene una segunda definición que
es algo que es mejor que el ordinario y
yo ahí me cuestiono y digo y qué pasa
con todos los demás con todos los
comunes de algo que yo estoy convencido
es de que nosotros podemos hacer cosas
extraordinarias desde un lugar ordinario
desde lo cotidiano
de hecho esta charla va dirigida para
todos nosotros los ordinarios que día a
día estamos intentando hacer pequeñas
cosas extraordinarias
cuando yo me involucré en el ecosistema
del emprendimiento impacto siempre
escuchaba una frase
enamórate del problema no de la solución
y nuevamente por definición un problema
siempre tiene una solución más allá de
que no le encontremos o nos cueste
encontrarla un problema tiene una
solución por lo que en el fondo también
es una frase que no me termina de
parecer suficiente y aquí mi propuesta
enamore monos también de las condiciones
porque con ellas debemos de convivir
y de pronto eso es lo que estamos
haciendo en sistema reconocimos e
identificamos de que no vamos a
modificar los patrones de cómo funciona
un mercado entre compradores y
vendedores pero si identificamos de que
hay formas para generar ajustes para que
ese sistema sea mejor estamos creando un
mejor sistema en donde las personas y
las empresas son más conscientes de sus
actos y de sus impactos
lo que empezó esta charla empezó con
esta gran pregunta y esta gran incógnita
de qué voy a hacer con estos 12 años de
mi vida
y después de haber hecho este viaje que
les he contado y reconocer de que
existen mecanismos para vivir con esta
tensión yo no me resigno a trabajar sin
la posibilidad de generar impacto
positivo
el promedio de 113 mil horas en
definitiva
es muy poco probable que vaya a cambiar
lo que también lo convierte en una
condición
por eso me gustaría terminar
preguntándoles cómo vamos a convivir con
esas 113 mil horas
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]